das was ein internationales
forschungsteam da identifiziert hat ist
wirklich ein extrem ungewöhnliches
himmelsobjekt konkret handelt es sich
dabei wohl um die seltene fusion zweier
weißer zwerge und zwar im sternbild
kassiopeia etwa 10.000 lichtjahre von
der erde entfernt und diese funktion
hatte ungeahnte folgen die wiedergeburt
eines sterns doch diese entwicklung
könnte schon bald für immer enden mit
einer supernovaexplosion science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen
dieser stern fund ist wirklich extrem
selten astrophysik teams aus deutschland
und russland haben wohl das produkt der
fusion zweier sternleichen aufgespürt
zwei so genannte weiße zwerge sind nach
einem jahr milliarden dauernden paar
tanz miteinander verschmolzen mehrere
milliarden jahre lang haben sich die
beiden weißen zwerge und kreist
gravitationswellen erzeugt und mit der
zeit an energie verloren letztendlich
haben sie sich angenähert und sich dann
zu einer einheit verschmolzen diese
fusion wird nach ansicht der experten
und expertinnen schon bald in einer
gigantischen explosion enden
griffin von der universität bonn betont
noch einmal die besonderheit dieses
fundes
ein solches ereignis ist extrem selten
in der ganzen milchstraße gibt es
vermutlich nicht einmal ein halbes
dutzend solcher objekte und wir haben
eines davon entdeckt
ursprünglich hatte ein russisches
astronomie team einen gasnebel auf
bildern des wide field infrared survey
explorer wise entdeckte im zentrum ein
extrem heller stern etwa 40.000 mal
heller als die sonne
schnell war den fachleuten klar dass sie
hier eine besondere entdeckung gemacht
hatten denn der gasnebel sendet kein
sichtbares licht sondern fast nur
infrarot strahlung aus die strahlung von
nebel und stern hatte dann ein
forschungsteam aus bonn genauer
analysiert dabei kamen die fachleute zu
einem ergebnis das das himmelsobjekt
wieder wasserstoff noch helium enthält
ein typisches charakteristikum von
weißen zwergen bei diesen leitwolfs
handelt es sich quasi um sternleichen
die sich am ende
der entwicklung von sternen bilden auch
wenn sie etwa so groß sind wie die erde
vereinigen sie eine gesamte sonnenmasse
in sich anfangs beträgt ihre
oberflächentemperatur 10 bis 100000
kelvin bei diesen hohen temperaturen ist
das vergleichbar mit grad celsius doch
weil sie über keine zusätzliche
energiequelle mehr verfügen kühlen sie
langsam aus und enden als schwarze
zwerge das passiert innerhalb von vielen
milliarden jahren weiße zwerge verfügen
also über eine nur noch geringe
leuchtkraft denn das helium und den
wasserstoff in ihrem innern haben sie
mit der zeit aufgebraucht zur erklärung
ihrer energie erzeugenden sonnenähnliche
sterne zunächst durch die fusion von
wasserstoffkernen nachdem dieser
verbraucht ist greifen sie auf helium
als brennstoff zu holen danach verließen
sie kühlen ab und sind dann weiße zwerge
das bedeutet dann in den meisten fällen
auch das ende dieser objekte doch bei
dem aktuellen fund j 00 53 1 1 war es
eben ganz anders und ganz und gar nicht
so der physiker norbert lang fast ist
folgendermaßen zusammen
wir vermuten dass sich dort vor vielen
milliarden jahren in enger nachbarschaft
zwei weiße zwerge gebildet haben diese
umkreisen einander und erzeugen dabei
exotischen verzerrung der raumzeit
sogenannte gravitationswellen zunächst
näherten sie sich an und verschmolzen
dann und dann passierte es dass sternen
feuer genommen wieder auf denn die
gesamtmasse der beiden objekte war
ausreichend um auch schwere elemente zu
fusionieren doch dieses wieder aufleben
wird nur kurz anhalten denn der stern
wird erlöschen sobald alle elemente zu
eisen verbrannt sind und dann erwarten
die fachleute einen kollaps begleitet
von einer supernovaexplosion der grund
die masse des sterns ist durch die
fusion der beiden weißen zwerg auf das
doppelte der sonnenmasse angewachsen
wenn er durch den einfluss seiner
eigenen kavitation in sich zusammenfällt
ergibt sich ein neutronenstern denn die
elektronen und protonen seiner materie
fusionieren zu neutronen und das
ergebnis eben dieser neutronenstern ist
gewaltig denn er misst dann sehe ich
nicht ein paar kilometer im durchmesser
liegt aber deutlich mehr als unser
gesamtes sonnensystem sein endgültiges
ende
ein kollaps mit einem gigantischen knall
einer supernovaexplosion supernovas vor
wird 2018 unbedingt dieses video
anklicken hier anschauen und abonnieren
und zwar raumzeit lockt der zukunft das
war ein video für den wissenschafts
videowettbewerb fast vor bezahlens und
den gibt es dieses jahr wieder wir
unterstützen ihn macht unbedingt mit
kriegt hier drauf hier
es gibt tolle preise ja also auf jeden
fall dabei sein bis dann bleibt dran